hey guys I'm solo Melina and this is a
review of spider-man homecoming this is
me testing out a new format that we
haven't actually done much of on this
channel for you guys ask for it actually
in our poll you can check out our poll
in the description by the way it's movie
reviewed now one of the reasons I've
hesitated before is because I think that
often movie reviews of the properties
you and I love they feel very surface
level you don't treat the movies as much
more than popcorn Flo I mean maybe
disagree with me if you'd like but I
think these films are as worthy of film
analysis and deeper critique as all
those art house flicks that when all the
Oscars so in these reviews if you like
them and we keep making them I think
we'd often talk about the choices made
by the story of the film and the
character arcs and how those choices
affected the film's overall quality if
that ain't up your alley
that's cool there's plenty of other
reviews out there for you to check out
and if you're looking for Easter eggs
and references that is totally cool too
they are definitely an entire aspect of
the movie going experience so that's
what our breakdown video is for check
that out but alright let's get to it
cast and characters now I'd be remiss if
I did still acknowledge our late actors
in this space Tom Holland in my opinion
just gave us the most authentic Peter
Parker to date note that I'm saying
Peter's not spider-man because that's
what stood out his portrayal to the guy
under the mat and the kid he really is
also I mean no [ __ ] he's gonna come off
as more authentically youthful Tom
Holland was a teenager when he was cast
as spider-man in the movie betty jokes
as spider-man probably like 30 and if
she's talking about the last guys she's
probably pretty close to right there
were both almost 30 when they were cast
now why am I so obsessively emphasizing
this youthfulness here well it's a
little-known fact that's the most
profitable superhero character in the
world is spider-man
when it comes to toys movies games
comics all of it added up spider-man
licensing outperforms every other
character by hundreds of millions of
dollars per year and the reason behind
that is because the main consumers of
licensed spider-man merchandise are
children so I'm not saying spider-man
needs to be useful because kids buy a
lot of his toys I'm saying spider-man is
the toy that kids already want the most
because he's authentically useful and
yes sure his mask is also very
recognizable and his colors are nice and
bright and they probably activate some
part of a kid's mushy little brain but
more importantly the character
is a child who kids can imagine
themselves becoming like when I was 13 I
loved Batman I still do but I couldn't
fantasize about waking up tomorrow and
being a billionaire in my 30s and having
been trained by the League of Assassins
and anyone I hoped that I'd become an
orphan other kids like Superman but they
couldn't imagine waking up tomorrow and
being an alien who's also an authority
but you know what I could dream of
waking up tomorrow and for some reason
or another suddenly having some extra
powers that I could use to beat up my
bully and suddenly be really good at
football or basketball or wrestling
becoming like spider-man is what every
teen dreams of so Marvel and Tom Holland
nail it here because the kids that sit
in the theater anywhere near this kids
age actually feel like that could be
them and their own little mushy escapist
fantasy brain this is also why one of
the fastest gaming properties on
spider-man is Harry Potter every kid's
dream to be a little British boy and
sticking to this feeling of relating to
this kid and the authenticity on display
that is why Michael Keaton nailed it as
the vulture and why in my opinion the
vulture character really worked Keane is
totally threatening as a villain but he
also manages to be threatening in a way
that many of us have actually felt in
real life as the girl you likes dad and
that's not the only dynamics you feel
like this is a real human being that
could really exist
the creative team Plus Keaton himself
designed the MCU movies first truly
authentic average Joe American
blue-collar villain now I don't care one
bit about who you voted for in the
election but every post-election
analysis was about who connected with
blue-collar voters better people don't
only attribute Trump's win to this
demographic but also the popularity of
Bernie Sanders and his platform in the
primaries so we can't deny right now in
2017 the blue-collar worker is having a
bit of a cultural moment they felt
ignored for decades now and even staying
out of politics when it comes to Marvel
movies they kind of have been ignored
there so here we didn't just get a
blue-collar hero in spider-man a kid
who's never even been on a plane before
but we got a blue-collar villain who
just loved his family and after a string
of bad luck he made some bad choices who
can't relate to that my own family is
full of examples of that same kind of
person and just like my family members I
don't hate Michael Keaton's vulture
I get him that's really rare for a
villain and not only is he relatable and
layered his art is just as interesting
as our protagonist you've got the
blue-collar guy typical of the
working-class seeing his career vanished
mostly due to advancements in technology
so in a good bit of ironing here he
decides to reject that narrative and use
technology to change his story he's not
going to be a victim or a statistic he's
going to turn the system around for him
and his family that's a lot more nuanced
than a bad guy who wants to make a blue
laser thing turn into a weird angry sky
cloud that's going to kill everyone
because he's mad okay now one criticism
you might have and I maybe will give you
is that this villain portrayal and
spider-man and their conflict and all
that stuff it's pretty small scale and
if you don't like that I get it you want
something more intense on these films
but personally I love that about this
movie with some exceptions that I will
bring up later this movie is smaller and
scale than the other MCU films because
that's the freaking point the movies
opening images show us tombs in its crew
cleaning up from the aftermath of
Avengers 1 and I think Eric's breakdown
dives into exactly what moment caused
this particular destruction but to me
this is doing a really great job of
setting up the entire setting and art of
this story like think about this the
rubble from an Avengers movie the
literal garbage that they left behind
that stuff when you shift perspective on
it it is enough to generate the entirety
of this spider-man's movie's plot and
villain motivations their trash is
literally this guy's treasures also
moments later when you see that happy
who is essentially like an assistant
level to Iron Man even he is too busy
dealing with MCU level of events for
Peter's phone calls even replying a
frickin little text message from the
kids so you can't tell me it was an
accident that this movie kept things
small and street level that's what they
wanted to do they positioned the entire
rest of the MCU as a point of
perspective for understanding Peter's
world and again you may not have wanted
a street-level superhero movie here's
why I did the MCU films take place on
this hugely epic scale they're only the
Netflix shows have really made you feel
what it's like to actually live in the
MCU like as
human being on your Street this movie
decides that street-level stories
shouldn't only be because you don't have
the huge budget these stories are just
as worthy of being told on the big
screen in some ways it's actually a
spiritual successor to ant-man because
our two leads see the Avengers as we do
larger than life way bigger than they
are and sure maybe it's not even a total
coincidence that that's the perspective
of the two heroes who are based on tiny
insects also getting specific about the
literal setting for a second the high
school I can barely remember the high
school scenes from the previous slide of
my movies but this movie it felt like
it's home base was the high school and
here's why that's important and why I
think it worked
director John Watts wanted to make a
movie that felt like the movies that
resonated with him when he was a
teenager and he felt like he was seeing
his own dramas and stresses on screen
and the best of those movies were the
John Hughes film just like how Logan had
a quick glimpse of the movie Shane to
evoke the feeling that this wasn't just
a superhero movie was also an old tragic
westerns this movie shows the clips in
Ferris Bueller's Day Off a John Hughes
movie to evoke that this is another
story about just a really crazy moment
in an average teens life so interesting
to make the high school almost a living
breathing character that feels realistic
watch really Minds that John Hughes vibe
I mean this movie could have just as
easily been set in The Breakfast Club
universe as in the MCU and the key to
that vibe was a high school that didn't
feel like it was full of clichés and
stereotypes was Flash Thompson much of a
bully threat no probably not but he is a
lot more like Rodolfo the annoying kid
who would try to make my life hell but
was also kind of dumb so yeah he's
Peters rodolfo Ned is what your friends
were really like everyone at this school
is actually really nerdy but they were
really real
I mean how perfect were those terrible
morning announcements I had the exact
same ones but they forgot to make the
music way too loud there's always ska
music science age myself
[Music]
also real quick actually Peters
relationship with on Bay was so damn
sweet and it's basically the
relationship between Molly Ringwald and
her dad and pretty-in-pink another John
Hughes classic okay moving on to the
story the things that happened in this
film the threat level the action scenes
the personal dilemmas there's another
reason why I love the choice to keep
them small in scale and it's also
connected to the idea to make this feel
like a John Hughes movie which was
Marvel daddy Kevin Feige nice idea by
the way and that reason that I love it
is because it's true to being 15 years
old look back at the things that
happened in this movie any of those
moments would of course be the most epic
thing to ever happen in a 15 year olds
life like I used to help kids write
their college essays and I guarantee you
that just being late to the academic
decathlon in DC would totally be their
answer to a time when I had to persevere
the most so as much as I can manage to
be relatable the events of the story
feel like fairly authentic teen life
being over stretched and over stressed
wishing you could skip the part of high
school where you have to grow up and
just wanting to be doing all the cool
adult stuff already wanting the girl and
then blowing it and then it's not
getting magically fixed you lose the
girl and that girl she also got her own
baggage too I'm going to say actually I
think the other spider-man movies they
might have had better action sequences
but I think part of the issue was they
had to tell a different story so in
terms of making your movie interesting
you take a character who is in some form
of stasis you make something kind of
crazy happen to him and then you put
them in a new environment well for them
the crazy thing was the spider bite and
the superpowers so their movie has to be
about the changes and differences from
being a normal team look how far away
from a normal team's life this kid story
has gone spider-man homecoming didn't
have to worry about that it got to tell
a different story this is after this
spider bite and even after Civil War so
don't ask me exactly what years
happening and because I got really
confusing I think Eric tries to figure
it out in his video instead this is now
like okay the spider bite is old news
you're back at school so now tell me an
interesting story and it doesn't become
about the difference between being a
regular kid and a super-powered kid it
becomes about the vast world of
difference that exists between your
perception of a hero and
reality of being a freakin ultra mega
Avengers level hero another way to put
it is that origin movies ask the
question of what happens when you become
super but this movie instead asks what
makes you the hero and trust me when I
say that most directors would rather
answer the second question diving into
who their character really is and not
just how they change when a super spider
spits on them it's actually why one of
the best runs of Superman comics in
recent history is the American alien
story by max landis it's not obsessed
with the circumstances of Superman's
origin it instead focuses on how weird
it is to try to be a normal human being
and a normal human team and an alien and
a freak but like the rest of us but also
different actually check that out if you
get a chance so did it work
here's where we know if the portrayal of
Peter Parker aiming small with his story
but making it feel really freakin true
works if you're having a really fun time
watching it laughing along with him
while he's in school and just enjoying
the film and then suddenly when Peter
stuck under rubble if suddenly you were
like wait am I kind of like tearing up
here then yes it works that means you
really buy that this kid is a real
freaking kid literally a child who is
hurt and so even though it's smaller
than you know star-lord versus a frickin
planet your heart actually feels it way
more and it actually breaks a little
when he says somebody help I'm stuck Oh
hmm so maybe that worked for you maybe
it didn't but it definitely worked for
me his struggle felt totally real and
that is way more important to me than
the quality of the CGI fight scene but
here's my criticism I kind of reference
it earlier this is a bit of a
double-edged sword we out here that very
real moment that small scale threat of
being trapped it worked
I felt it but you know what I didn't
feel the threat when Peter was stuck on
the outside of a plane a thousand feet
up in the air and it's about to crash
into the ground it's a major action
sequence and it didn't really resonate
for me and honestly it didn't feel that
threatening but I got a wonder if that's
just because
Bhaiji put it out there that he was
looking for writers and directors that
could create a great movie about a
team's life and not looking for people
who nail it with huge CGI action
set-pieces
and if I had to pick between those two I
definitely make the character pick every
time but sure it'd be nice to nail both
also I'm going to mention that the
trailers did not do us any favors and
making the
action set-pieces land the plane and the
big ferry sequence were both heavily
given away in the trailers and I know
you might find this ironic coming from
me about seeing too much in trailers but
keep in mind I don't dictate what goes
in the trailer I just comment on it I
very much prefer less given away one of
my favorite trailers in recent memory
used no footage from the actual show
with Jessica Joan or it didn't really
give anything major away like that first
force awakens trailer and I break down
to the trailers where some of my
favorite ones I've ever done okay so
I'll say I like this movie a lot and
it's important to remember it just feels
right for where Peter is right now at
this moment in his story sure he might
become more like Tony Stark in the
future and he's actually going to be in
freakin infinity war where story gets
ridiculously epic I think he's going to
space like as if now he's never been on
a plane but I think you go into space
but right now it's perfect for a 15 year
old superhero I mean I might have bought
if the story was about a pea coach that
embarrasses you in front of the class
just because you asked if you could
split up the mile run over a couple of
different days which is a totally
reasonable request coach Miller anyway
I'm glad John Watson team just Tony
Stark's device about staying close to
the ground because that is where
spider-man works best he's just like one
of your friends who lives in your
neighborhood
okay now I'm trying to come up with a
fun name for the sequel of this movie I
think the third one has got to be
graduation but what the hell do you call
the middle one final exam midterm I know
let me know if you have any ideas for
that or more likely you can respond to
the points I brought up in this video I
will talk more about it in the comments
also let me know if you like these
reviews it's a new thing we're trying it
was your idea and if you feel like this
review actually made some good points I
would really appreciate it if you shared
it around with some of your friends I
think it's our duty to raise the
discussion around these badass nerdy
properties I've been phill'd Molina have
a good one
bye bye